laredo
three yeah
three oh whoa boy oh my god
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy it's freedom
oh boy oh boy i can't wait
to listen to my favorite can't wait
to talk and make the episodes
there are time like in the early
nineteen hundreds where if you said oh
boy like a parent with scold you
like don't say that like like it
was cursing like it were kami was
common yeah something like that oh interesting
yeah like you say say oh well
like in the music man where it's
like using words like swell yeah and
mr what does it mister galleys we've
been
mr ali's week vegas uncle somebody's whiz
bang okay uncle billy's whiz bang something
like hugh jackman starring in the music
man i know with a friend of
mine isn't available as well really jackie
romeo belgian well anyone to say but
best friends romeo belgian wall woe from
star trek know that's renewal bears oh
that's right because young
oh so yes yes renee has passed
passed on i i'd not cool yeah
not not as cool as you think
i was saying hello everybody was his
son every sing but he did die
doing a crazy stunt so that's true
no it's not my ca if every
single person on earth still was alive
yeah would that be cool no like
really living with a special crowd and
there's a
a lot of people we don't know
lifting how many people how many people
have died okay why you gotta be
nice out there
ah um what what came before caveman
there was some who was the missing
link well there's her like those lucio
fish people lizard down that lizard people
are still here can i share some
good news bible people yeah yes or
the word of god are you gonna
tell me prison i know
i'm not gonna tell you that but
i am gonna tell you that guy
you already know my goodness baseman tell
the listener that you know my neighbors
who thought i was i had called
animals yeah i did not do neither
did mike yes good too good to
reset it okay then what was the
situation again for those v who haven't
heard right and wrong attention the neighbor
who i who had said hi to
in the past
multiple times right walks up to my
store with like that classical type knocked
on the door and then basically said
someone called animal control and i like
shit i say i think if you
wish that your only one i don't
know and i'm like well pi one
who does know he was who called
it because they know what you're doing
and i don't know you and i
don't care
yeah but anyways long story short ever
since then i've tried to say hi
again i've i've wanted to say i
didn't call you know call your ears
you were saying you might do that
like knock on our door and say
hey i don't feel like there was
a misunderstood really wanna do it because
i was feeling really i've just been
a local and i need to look
at us
ooh nice understanding they like they don't
even like look enough so that you
have a window to say hello you
don't mean like oh see them outside
and and our properties are close it's
like you know i were i see
them a lot what are they like
ah a foot away or one inch
oh no but no they're not like
that but they but they are often
right out front i can see them
i think about that sometimes when i
was in apartments and i would have
an upstairs neighbor i'd be like that
person is literally like three feet away
yeah that is weird i'm standing there
that they're just like circling you with
both in ah yeah
eat radius well anyways i just wanna
say so i've been wanting to like
you get the guy's attention and say
hey and just even say hi nicely
not even doing engage and then i
also wanted to go just you know
we really didn't call i feel like
there might you might think we did
whatever and then i was kind of
going like god i wish they would
move like i'd be saucepan then we
were having this conversation where like they
never would like right why why would
anyone move like maybe like one of
the i
in the world ever move but what
are these jai there's a lot of
people i hate are gonna move yeah
yeah and then that's luck a couple
days ago i saw a person putting
up a for sale sign in front
of their house and i leaped to
my feet like a mature house huh
you want to do something nice for
valentine's i got so excited and i
texted him the picture he was like
holy shit oh
now my fantasy is when i see
them to go oh my god i'm
so happy you're moving ah by the
way i didn't call animal yeah you
know by the way i didn't call
them but i will now what if
you just lied and said yeah i
did do it goodbye yeah i mean
i don't i don't i call animal
control all the time i don't want
that on my home on you i'm
gonna firstly i mean just with them
yeah sophia animal from home alone yeah
anyways why regulations oh i am so
happy we're happy thing you and i
really hope like maybe when your tax
family lives in it just was mike's
family maybe nice fam oh my family
although my family not a nice family
yeah the day you told us i
was it just was the the highlight
of our was i smiled for the
rest of the day yeah i thought
so
so i can i tell you something
jamie i love to look out our
window and talk shit about the people
that we see it's so fun really
fun yeah we like to start what
we like it's it's it absolutely is
based on nothing but we'll see somebody
we didn't we've never seen before on
our street and one of us will
say
who the fuck is that
fuck that more what's she doing so
yeah anytime i see anyone with glasses
when we're driving oga fucking nerd
ah and still do what sheila
nerd always a coincidence you're gonna tell
us i this was fun oh boy
i say i know about this already
yes okay i got an invitation from
ah our friend a eva andrew eve
anderson to go to the magic castle
because her she's a member her father
harry anderson of course was a member
of tell everyone a little bit about
the magic castles so that they understand
because i
didn't know about this well know i've
famously talked about it in my standup
hour driving and crying everyone stop this
episode crying and driving is a drive
which is dan's rye i believe it
was drawn by climbing i believe it
was driving and cribbing durbin curbing and
your enthusiasm
ybor yeah and you remember what der
means you don't remember what derby mean
i feel you i tell you what
was well isn't the wheel dirt i
don't care everybody there ah before making
it work is doors the willow my
nerve is sucking pain it's ah
alright yeah yeah in chicago i got
counted only if you're i got a
message from someone that i grew up
with and there's one for every city
supplies yes i do my solo like
that was low
so maybe it's probing
huh anyway um and so yeah well
the magic castle is ah is a
oh i'll take it from here
i thought you were skipping over the
magic castle's a private club in ah
in los angeles it is the where
the the members of the academy of
magical arts hang out they perform they
do shows there you get invited by
someone it's invitation only but it's easy
to get the invitations um
you get invited to go there and
you can have dinner and watch all
these shows and everything it's really fun
pause for a second you'd say it's
easy to get the invitations and it
is i've been a few times but
how am i getting these i don't
even know it's like someone that goes
i know a magician and i got
a ticket you wanna come it's like
you have to know a magician yeah
but you know what it turns out
you i'm behind him for this reason
i met you if you've never been
no of course you and i know
eva of course oh yeah comedy right
right right there's but there's always somebody
that you're just a couple degrees away
from you know yeah and but but
of course i say that because we're
in showbiz but obviously everyone there is
not necessarily in showbiz brain it the
place is packed like apple really it's
a fun you don't have that many
people in showbiz
oh it's it's my monday's high one
time and there's like you can walk
around and there's magicians doing little performances
like for a few people yeah i'm
always going to room level like yeah
there's a close-up at your room which
is like fifty seats yeah what you're
really yeah it's really fun and like
you if you're sitting at the bar
like somebody will come over and start
doing tricks for you or whatever and
it's
really like if you but you must
give yourself over to the spirit of
it you know what i mean you
can't you can't be a sandy like
oh i know yeah how you did
that no
i love magic because i really very
rarely have any idea what just happened
yeah i like to say i'm not
i'm never someone who tries to figure
it out i am somebody who just
likes to wonder how did they do
that i'm someone who tries to figure
it out just because i you sued
due to arrive like investigated traced your
lawyer yeah well derek de la guardia
gaudio zelek delgaudio and gaudio show ah
like i i was fascinated with it
and started trying to figure out how
he did i did enjoy that i
figured all that out where what does
that streaming as it was happening that
was on it was through amazon or
in whom something yeah but that's a
really great show in and of itself
yeah yeah that was interesting so we
got invited now initially we are going
to
go with scott and co op yeah
and oh man oh i was brendan
so excited yeah oh but undo any
man guess whoa cu got the cove
cool i've got qubit cu guga tho
co
and she they could not go anymore
can't believe it and so we then
invited ah our friends nate and tawny
and they could go so we all
go together we're having a good time
wow i'll go down together that's right
we were in vienna this was the
match councils in me and i'm ever
gotcha
um in the sixties and um so
we're apt to were at the bar
before we were going to go see
the shows and everything and i noticed
that tony is drinking and ah a
weird drink i say what are you
drinking she says it's an espresso martini
yeah and i don't like exactly okay
and i said what made you drink
that
she said kevin barnett our other friend
he loves them and he gets them
all the time so i thought i
would try it but i don't like
it it seems like a really specific
taste and mentally
i i'm not a fan of coffee
boost on me i'm not a fan
of coffee at all but i but
i still think it is not a
fan of liquid oh you've got a
problem money because you need to drink
it every three days oh i eat
ice
that you are a fan of liquid
you don't even know what those are
solid science fi edge he blinded me
good heavens to talk about yo beautiful
oh my why didn't we ever get
to see her i want to judge
for myself i know i'd say she'd
probably say i mean it's objective like
thomas dolby standards maybe attend but for
us it's said we live in hollywood
beauty is subjective accept in hollywood i
don't know who she is but i
bet sakamoto who
she's a science too she's an l
a too she's an ohio ten
ohio don't get mad but with an
oakland booty
location ohio face but an oakland booty
okay okay okay please the worst of
both worlds and so ah the evening
goes on we watch a lot of
shows we're having a lot of fun
we are in this is right before
about to go to dinner in this
piano bar which is fun it's right
next to the main bar where tonic
and gin yeah yeah
regular crowd shuffled on the arm on
piano at the magic castle that yellow
is itself plays itself and i'm gonna
request you sent you talk to it
and go hey play this the idea
is that it's a ghost named irma
and you can request songs of irma
and irma will play them and it's
really fun irma struck out a lot
with us that protect sometimes she doesn't
know the song and just
i was like a bank yeah yeah
but she knew a lot she knew
what kind of songs were you requesting
verma oh like some people were making
up songs that don't really exist and
were like you're striking out our wrap
um i can't remember what we requested
i remember nate had one song that
he really wanted her to play and
blue oyster cult godzilla
i'd love to hear that the yeah
sure i'd love to hear it at
all i do not know what that
song is oh you never played guitar
hero back in the you know what
i the only time i play guitar
hero it was the beatles version oh
yeah and it was so fucking fun
because you it's the only time i
got ever played it i could ever
do
i could ever move my hands in
a instrumental way and sing at the
same time which i cannot do it
i don't know why i never played
it i bought it oh so you
bought colonials so you've got the whole
of the beatles no cool up and
i played guitar hero one and two
and and had so much fun with
it and then we bought the beatles
when i never opened it
gotta need their entire to have no
well no it was the last i
think it was the last video game
i ever played i basically was just
like you know what i'm wasting too
much time on this never played wow
someone gave me their entire guitar hero
getting the drum kit and began a
drum kit played it like four times
although drunk not to put a pin
in this story for a second but
sure while i'm
minded of it yeah the reality recap
yeah oh lovely
this season is hot hot hot okay
so love slide i just want to
bring up you interrupted the store i
just wanted to bring up the woman
who is like what they're looking for
here yeah they're gonna move in together
and this and this guy is very
neat very fastidious i like him and
and she's like well where are we
going to put my video games
and he's like oh away nikos no
i like to leave him out nick
is i feel like he's such a
good person in the relationship and she's
really sleepy than she has so many
insecure securities she's always going my flaws
my flaws won't shut up about her
flaws and just see what good she
loves you he loved you i worry
she was actually
saying my flaws my she literally says
my flaws i have so many flaws
my flaws because of my flaw but
i want her to say my flaws
my fly practically did but she was
like well i got to leave the
drumset out yeah i know so and
she made him put on a hotdog
or organized costs cause hot dog and
she's like i answer the door like
this party so you just wait but
so she seemed fun in ah in
the way that cool up like has
cooled cool right before i forget this
yes great jonathan ah cats joke is
i i had i was just in
new york i hadn't been there in
a while and it was an elevator
in the elevator operator says call out
your flaws and i said i'm impatient
with the elderly
nice i like ah but but i
just know i thought it was the
most whimsical place where i started to
like no i deny of like wax
at the same clubhouse fun but he
didn't mind it he he didn't mind
he acted like i said a race
this thing in the way you reacted
to that joke really interrupting just because
reality stone right when you are happy
to give you a big guy wow
i'm offended yeah that's right texting you
you take so fast i know i
let your joke or you're just in
the middle of talking about this contest
but that's why i say oh you
were in the middle of talking about
something else that's right do you want
to hear the radio only thing you
want
the thing i would do want to
say about him is he's like
no just put them away what are
we twelve yeah no he's like really
real word but but i also understand
not keeping video games as the video
games girl she's also like video and
she talks like this would blow everyone's
shoes while they're all from chicago hear
the news yeah that's no sorry and
she's probably just like seven years younger
than him or
language is part of it he's going
like i'm kind of in a stage
where but his his place was kind
of childish too i would say yeah
here he didn't have the greatest place
and then she was like hey i'm
like a ball pit sometimes nobody just
have like his room was sort of
like boy's room you know it wasn't
right yeah one race car bed um
adult no shame had the only nice
nice place i shane wonder why me
in the weirdest way and then by
the end i was like he's what
i thought he was yeah it was
just like yeah no luck anyway
so speaking of alcohol you remember the
seed i planted about the espresso motel
for all i'm thinking about i just
i can practically taste it so like
what ninety minutes later we are in
the piano bar with the ghost pianist
whom should watch in but the formation
and kevin martel wow just getting there
with his significant other in their friends
wow we we conjured him know tommy
was not supposed to be there whoa
she imagined if i had been there
i wouldn't have been talking about him
i always talked about kevin i talked
about all the talk about kevin yes
because normally
i'm talking about impure like who is
that understand you're like chef kevin but
i mean what does so the timing
of the habit of going shove it
of course who knows because we weren't
we got there in stages we weren't
all there at the exact same time
so we sit we were in the
bar for a different amount of time
than we would have been had we
who knows if you guys have been
there maybe you would
gotten there earlier than nate and tony
because they're coming from further away they
were the last people something like that
just doesn't it's not a coincidence it's
fun my opinion it's a fate at
the end of the night we go
out we're waiting for our cars and
you beat the shit out of kevin
we wanted to get a man it
was satisfying i was like i'm sick
i'm hungry
um we are getting food they have
like a step and repeat they used
to do as i famously talked about
in my standup special they used to
do pictures at the table they go
around to the table and charge you
way too much money for a picture
of your group but now they just
have a step and repeat outside and
you get somebody to take a picture
of they need a dedicated person to
do that so if they're they're doing
it on your cell phone yes so
we asked
one stranger they did a piss poor
job yeah yeah don't focus up if
somebody asks you take doctor the guy
and they've got all this second lower
you to do it yeah this is
an important thing don't fuck around with
yes this guy so he did a
terrible job are you gonna propose to
one of us there's like a box
there and i'm just yeah you have
a box next to us next to
you take a leather yeah are you
gonna pr
oppose to one or both of us
don't look at that okay we get
the okay at first i thought it
was a pencil sharpener everything you laid
down bringing it up now i think
it's maybe watching probably brought pencil sharpener
so you're out there getting some routers
first guy takes pictured sucks fuck this
somebody else where our cars are about
to arrive somebody else comes we see
somebody else walk out like oh quickly
can you take a picture of us
yeah yeah absolutely
she took a picture of us it
was great and then she says to
tani who is one of the star
of star trek lower decks by the
way i'm the production coordinator on lower
decks oh another weird tani related colorado
tommy's out there in these streets just
talking about people these manifesting these coincidences
it was a fun
magical tawny evening i love so glad
you had such a good time without
me yeah i'm i'm glad i wasn't
invited at all
let me ask you this because i
because i this is something you would
know it's probably what you would never
know but can you how much can
you do with the baby now can
you can you get somebody to look
after the baby you have a regular
hero when you tell me maybe hannah
play with me i can the baby
talk can reason with the barry yes
absolutely i don't have a sit
or yet but that's my big thing
that i'm working right now but why
don't you just do it babysitter yeah
i go back to your job or
ah everything that makes pays you to
watch the um but i and i
love being around her all day long
um but i might you know when
nighttime comes wow i'm gonna party i
do get very tired night but
i just offered for my friend i'm
gonna watch her daughter tomorrow night when
she goes on a date with her
husband i just thought oh why don't
why haven't i offered this to her
and then she said she would do
the same so i definitely have somebody
for at least one fun yeah maybe
um yeah right because we were talking
you've never been to our house yeah
and it would be nice
to have you guys oh and love
to but even for that you could
bring hollywood but i think that would
be fine the way then i the
ideal thing would be to do it
a little earlier oh that's no problem
for us right damn you like a
dinner at i don't know six damn
it's
yeah thanksgiving dinner at six am that's
great we love eating early yeah i
got a few especially going out to
eat early and then you have like
the rest of the night yeah it's
like you've had to sleep
yeah man we eat we go to
a restaurant six come home we're home
by eight we immediately go to sleep
i tell you about the magic castle
when i went and there we went
to the close-up room and the guy
the guy the magician kept doing fake
fuck ups you know how in a
in a yes yes yes yeah they
kept doing like oh right does this
her card and then you'd go no
and you'd go huh maybe because this
is and then he'd do it and
even bigger yes yes so we kept
doing those but then he also was
actually fucking up the tricks half the
time as well marked so it was
never know what's what exactly so he
just ended out a friend in the
crowd that he kept talking to
who was another magician or something who
just like he kept doing all these
decides to like oh i didn't do
that one right or whatever and then
at a certain point he like fucked
up a trick and he goes and
and and the the person didn't say
the right card that he had prepped
to me the guard that was right
he's like and he goes yeah someone's
getting something spy
chel in their milkshake tomorrow morning what
the fuck don't know i've never been
able to understand it well it might
have just been some ad-lib that didn't
make sense i don't i think that's
exactly what what what do you think
he meant though i think he meant
nothing and i think he was trying
because you kind of shit into someone's
milkshake oh morning that in their morning
a nation that almost made me gag
but no this was to his friend
who i know oh my god i
was watching something and i almost threw
up the other day the pen fifteen
finale which i thought was fantastic but
there was no winners every point during
it where i actually stood up and
almost threw up wow and if you've
watched it you probably know what i'm
talking why don't you stand
up because you thought you were going
to yeah well i leaped off the
couch like oh my i'm gonna throw
up and then i i almost threw
up and then i had to um
not look for the next like thirty
seconds and then and then i had
to not throw up yeah and i
just focused and it went away but
oh my god i've never i've never
thrown up watching something that was telling
me what it is i can't tell
you what but because of your
watching if you'd like to show yeah
you need to watch the show well
but one time it happened but watch
this gif ahead it's a sex scene
in the oh no yeah there's a
penis going vagina because that would make
me no good huh now as a
devout christian that no no no but
it's a but it's evenly marriage oh
this show is if the bible doesn't
like it thirteen year
fourteen-year-old yeah so it's it's a disturbing
sort of moment and i maybe almost
threw up in if i guess it
will you tell me yeah it does
a hyman burst no
shit when that happens it covers the
roman blood yeah
ah it's like something out a seven
the shining shiny not theory oh my
god um i learn what's on your
shirt it's got it's a billie eilish
t-shirt that i was sent in the
mail for free
it looks um it looks cool because
it looks like a vintage shirt i've
warned about eight thousand times because when
i got it in the mail for
this like promotional thing it was like
the only shirt that fit me like
recently had a baby and so it
was like a revelation thanks it would
if it was a good shirt for
that to wear on every day and
then um recovery
whether it's now it looks like an
old cool shirt but it does warn
that one hundred times yeah okay yeah
it's not
ah t-shirt
plain t-shirt plain t-shirt plane please
i'm like an everything t-shirt and well
my future i will say ice cream
the everything bagel ice cream from jimmy
i don't want sent it to me
no i'm afraid of that always everybody
getting said ice cream but me i
know everyone gets jenny's in the mail
so i look i'm afraid of the
i don't know i could i i
don't i want i don't want to
disclose how i got this ice cream
well you will off mic i will
off my yeah certainly because i want
that shit yeah get yeah you should
that everyone deserve it i've thank you
but i want to try that everything
bagel ice cream no no everyone says
it's will come into the house afterwards
i saw fuckin tim cal paris got
it yeah well he's one of the
greatest greek american writers comedy writers sorry
i should let me do more qualifiers
do you think that's one of his
generation of ah white pop when i
say generation i mean the exact
he was haunted and under-rated the greek
american committee writer others just caliber and
generation was born between july and september
of yeah he did it he did
a video where he tastes he tasted
it looked like he the way he
described it i was like that's kind
of what i was hoping it would
taste like oh little squirrel high little
squirrel over that little guy
you're far away from my home
he's like paul i ran every man
you forgot to fill up the bucket
in the intervention if you fill a
bucket with water no filled with the
hazel nuts oh yeah you fill a
bucket with water lord yeah what do
you do fill a bucket with water
fill a bucket with water for the
animals to swim in
big animals try to drink from it
i'm like ah no it's a swimming
water i put up a sign with
a dog drinking and i put a
line through it to know totally like
when people put those signs like the
ghostbusters yeah yeah thank the ghostbusters know
people put a picture of a dog
shitting yeah and they put the red
circle with a line through
doc shit it's you just gotta pick
it up right or do they just
know no option you know what this
dogs to shit they don't want it
at all you try telling a dog
not to shit well that's the thing
it's like is this supposed to be
for the dog yeah yeah like the
dogs like that looks like me think
i should tell you that yes yeah
oh that's a no do they understand
the ghostbuster symbol dogs
love ghostbusters because they're scared of ghosts
while also there are those demon dogs
in it and they're like that could
be me one day oh young girl
the cayman dogs my ate a lot
in college because the my college nepal
the logo the mascot daemon what devil
is that true when dion dogs where
or a hot dog ah it was
a hot talking nearby demon demon there
was nah nah you're fine
huh there was a hotdog place nearby
that sold demon dogs and those understand
i'll talk under the owl to go
oh go the out alleyways if you
really fuckin great was nast greece nest
yeah it was the ah my love
their books was the um was the
the mascot a demon or a devil
i think because the devil is like
in charge of demon oh and let
me write this so if it was
a demon they'd be having their time
card and yeah let me look it
up because i do think the blue
diamond knows i'm blue demons was yeah
that's intense blue demons i mean why
are they blue because devils are red
because our glow than their bell the
blue demons are nice they just play
sport
odds are they cold yes ideally i
can see dirty mens there though the
names from heaven hell is hot heaven
is called rye yes so everyone's freezing
up and so it sucks i mean
they have those grow only a robot
yeah maybe the halo get off heat
like a heat lamp i hope so
i don't know could you turn
on the halo two
please turn on my ah
guy here we believe closer to halo
um whoa wait go back ah the
demons huh hotdog ball mascot shit what
made you think of hotdog over there
demon dogs oh that's what i wanna
talk about dude are you familiar with
devil dogs the snack ah what is
it devil dogs yells
dogs dev level devil dogs they were
like a long um k ooh kind
of thing oblong cake thing with cream
in the middle yeah sounds familiar i
think they're regional they were maybe a
drake's cake um and they were is
it like a whoa or whoa is
that what oh i didn't know it's
not like stout frosted ironing dong
but no it's not like a ding-dong
because the cake is just cakey it's
not like cover with chocolate so it's
a chocolate cake but it's it's it's
so chocolate cake dry coming up it's
so happy brie spices shawn trying to
trying to pretend it's not happening
yeah if you mentioned chocolate cake it's
going to happen fuck man that sucks
i got to stay away from it
i like talking about luck it's alright
but if you don't want to hear
about cosby who
watch that that doc here no i
hear yeah it's goodness yes before um
we need to talk about cars do
you do is chocolate cake your favorite
dessert of all time what is your
favorite deserve i know we've member to
be ambitious yeah yeah i mean ice
cream i think is is the ultimate
dessert like it's a thing that i
will like rally pretty much every time
yeah
ice cream is the ultimate you know
you gotta get jam changers like i
feel like i feel like ice cream
the worst ice cream i've ever had
is probably it depends on the flavor
so do you know what i mean
but like chocolate cake can be bad
chocolate can be bad yeah you know
that case the worst like bad pizza
eve
in the worst pizza is still pizza
i don't know like you know what
i had
you know what's really good um i
think my favorite kind of ice cream
is like chip witches were and then
like a sandwich made with cookies yeah
kind of being the kind of ice
cream that's in chip which know it's
like chocolate chip cookies with you because
i remember sure not your way ice
cream well that's ice cream treat that
i would get from an ice cream
truck and they sell it at trader
joe's
and i eat one last day debate
is it like a funny trader jose
or trader its traitor traitor traitor what
was that any more traitor burr they
stopped
traitor burr is he's from the crazy
semi-sheer show like a frozen prospector did
they stop doing that because i thought
that was so easy they did they
did as a little there was funny
no one ever told me years later
joe doors there was a funny click
whole thing about them erasing the legacy
of trader ming
that there are whitewashing
but um ah so so ice cream
and ice cream is great chocolate if
it's like a dense i love a
dance chocolate cake how do you make
it when i've made you a few
cakes in my day your cakes are
good man but how do you make
it to be dead on mike i
don't know what determines the density of
chocolate cake but when it's like really
do
dense and the only time acceptable or
ingredients yeah more ingredient because two eggs
put four in their dense but still
creamy yeah i wonder if the actually
easily jensen sweet just double every no
no that doesn't make any sense
this cake has the density of a
black hole how do you make something
denser i don't know man i gotta
look you're the baker you're the bomb
the candlestick maker name or whatever yeah
yes
those are three roles yes we should
change the title of the show but
your bigger counseling yeah let's recognize visibility
measure travel survey who can say fastest
tie that time cause i'm a tall
right time and time to time it
and have it be ah still like
you can understand what's being said okay
what's the word for that uh
um are understandable that yeah ok lauren
you ready yes three to one like
your baker california i forgot that there's
gonna be
there will be no go after one
okay okay three two one but your
baker candlestick maker i hit lap
just crazy but this is like happens
every single three
why are we always stuffing this huh
three two one butcher baker candlestick maker
one point eighteen seconds not bad now
about one second is very smell was
the long okay i'm going to really
try okay i feel i tried to
you know this time i got it
okay three two one butcher baker candlestick
maker
one point zero two hey you beat
lawrence time do you want me to
do you please oh do me do
me baby alright let me find clock
okay let's be fun talk we ready
yes three two one butcher baker candlestick
maker one point two four that wasn't
good because i
yeah i mean don't break now wanna
try it again i feel like i
need a sec okay lauren hugo i'm
not gonna press lap okay here we
go three two one but your bigger
candlestick maker one point four
even worse okay let's try trying to
get us to be really clear right
right here we go ready three two
one but your baker candlestick maker one
point one one yeah you beat me
hey did you know you didn't be
me hold on no eight to be
you know the quickest you are the
quickest i don't remember what mine
right ready ball three s to one
butcher baker candlestick maker one point one
the quickest so far i'm gonna start
i'm gonna try mine ready you're gonna
time yourself yeah no no that's that's
illegal ready three two one butcher baker
candlestick maker
that sounds crazy but for major heels
like a point nine zero yeah you're
the winner but rebecca kinsler bigger what
does spoke like that in life one
for microcap stock maker would if i
were an auctioneer we have to take
a break we'll be right back
and we're back boy i'm still basking
in the glow that mr baker candlestick
maker should be like your word impressive
yeah thank you so much for buying
this previously that was so we did
we will have to get an engrave
though how are you sticking your name
conversation into us doing know if i
told you that you'd know and you
know i would win because
it's inscribed miseries joke too slowly oh
okay we we've rigged it you could
have spoken oh my god but you're
getting spoiled i was like huh well
i got back my that not to
mention that danielle from love is mine
looks just like
dementia right now but like that looks
like a cardassian really she went through
a transformation really yeah i saw a
ah magazine at the supermarket grats paul
well there's more did the leisure read
it and pick you up and hold
or did they say this ain't a
library i was told this ain't a
librarian i had to go back oh
no um it was
was ah you know some like star
people whatever the fuck are just like
us picture of no star not just
like us stars like enquirer star no
it was not like tabloid he was
more like a us weekly kind of
shit uh-huh and it was picture of
that's kim kardashian yeah and you can't
live as a tabloid yeah i feel
like nash
all enquirers well that's next level with
lulu it yeah i i i think
there are two just yeah there there
should be a distinction between those two
types of tabloid magazine do you think
the people at the enquirer like have
a lot of fun making the articles
because it's basically like celebrity onion yeah
you just see what i realized that
it would be fun yeah
gen in tears after brad says hi
isn't that the guy though who had
all the the dirt on trump and
everything in his safe oh yeah yeah
okay anyway he declined to release it
so it was a picture of kim
kardashian and hot heat what's his name
p davidson davidson and the headline was
how they fell
in love like i do they have
knows people who want yeah yeah absolutely
zero questions except ah
how did these guys get together kanye
released a video today that were used
like he buried varying pete davidson and
the ground at at a certain point
it like it's already stocking yeah but
isn't that a threat yeah but i
mean like could certainly be construed as
such yeah like therapy david's a whole
sending which i'm not remember that many
flowers is stock
being i don't know he's i didn't
hear about the serbs man he is
at sucks it sucks it sucks it's
not funny at all it's just that
training it's it's know that some people
think it's funny i know but that's
a really weird that's weird i liken
it to like we're watching o j
simpson in real-time but she probably has
more security so she's prob
probably safer but we're watching another o
j simpson thing happened in real time
with a guy on mike admitting he's
like the first song on his epee
was like i dreamt about killing u
s night it's about campbell yeah you're
going yeah about kim yeah oh my
god yeah so it's like scary i
didn't know that rude
yeah it's uncalled for i would say
it's ungentlemanly at the very least and
it's scary i don't i don't like
that i don't know looks i don't
like it if someone wants to break
up with you know this is all
it's all cracked and shit oh i
just saw that it was green oh
yeah it's green though luck of the
irish wakes you in for st paddy's
i went to st patrick's day
it's cause i'm gonna get blackout drunk
like i always do it's gonna go
to every bar actually are we allowed
are we allowed to celebrate it anymore
or stop and cancelled for wow we
are unfortunately still celebrated i wish we
weren't yeah well last year so i
want you know in chicago they say
there's my river greenway this might come
out
the day that st patrick says or
it might be the week before so
i just want to think it's no
never no more okay but they dye
the river green and chicago with i
think they didn't do it last year
in an effort to deter people from
celebrating st patrick's day because they hove
it yeah by the way watching love
is blind and seeing chicago i loved
that
the bachelor parties were making me go
like god who would be great to
go to chicago but then was awesome
but then okay so the conversation about
chicago to go to wrigley field and
i'm like rick really feel some possessive
sorry i'm telling you chicago i'm like
i don't eat i don't so the
chicago wrigley's field they go to rick
mister
wrigley's field okay mrs fields is there
making a week so we put gum
and cookies famous amos's is also there
oh my god oh god
okay so then i bet i bet
they say sure i can tell it's
disgusting what you wouldn't eat okay with
a hook and a piece of bubblegum
know you're you're a better man
oh hey go in an unholy thought
but here's here's what speaking oh i
thought you said font but that's why
i wanted to say what an unholy
flat you know there's a thought that
the catholic church forbids but that's why
i want to say they go to
wrigley field and i'm like how quick
sand that would be fun but then
i then i realised i don't care
about going to wrigley field i just
like the font that the sign is
in the the science great but you
know what i would it wouldn't be
like i'd be like wow i'm so
old-fashioned i wouldn't necessarily care specifically that
i'm on wrigley field it's like going
right i'm very excited to be on
a baseball field actually i was thinking
this is cool for anyone because even
if you don't care about baseball who
gets to go on the field oh
yeah i've been on
the dodger stadium field i've been on
ah when we want to understand and
feel when i was the batboy i
told you about this when i was
about right and then the other day
when yeah i've enough when the kids
get to run the field that i
am i love that so much yeah
i love that so much do you
know about us know if you go
on a special day where it's kids
run
in the bases after the game so
fucking cute it's so cute to see
these kids running but so you let
you send all the kids down and
they start running around you don't well
you you accept your and your company
them and then you don't run the
bases yourself you can like let them
go and then then you you travel
around behind the bases yeah wait for
them that's really sweet but the one
thing i would
i'd say to anyone who's going to
do it the line is so fucking
wrong yeah but goes incredibly fast because
they're running because it because they're running
like twenty people at a time on
these bases so it's like yeah it's
not like one goes around it's like
there's always somebody on a base yeah
but it was the line was so
incredibly long and we saw so many
people going like
too long you don't want to wait
right um holocaust said that too and
um
man so many of the kids were
like yeah forget it and then they
would leave that's that's why it moves
too fast and then our nephew was
like should we do this and and
people around me were like it's really
quick and so we stayed and literally
like fifteen minutes it was around the
entire stadium minutes later we were around
the bases on a profess
national exponential madly field grilling me well
i thought it was legal and i
enjoyed that love is blind was in
chicago because i just liked seeing the
sights i've been home in a couple
years now which is yeah but the
the little ah the the boat going
around the the river looked fun too
well yeah well actually that's where i
worry about oh you worked on that
by not that specific i don't think
the specific one but i
color at the boat yeah yeah oh
tour yeah um for very short-lived moment
what would you say again boat rides
thirty minutes on lake sixty minutes on
the river and i will say the
architectural tour in chicago on the river
at sixty minutes it's fantastic i would
love to do that it's really great
i would totally go to that level
so do it today okay i'll book
the tickets collapse coming back into town
i i i'm going to switch places
at the chicago right now get on
a tour we're gonna switch places yeah
like freaky friday mentally oh shit she's
already there so i'll skip the ride
to which we've talked about free fridays
before i think it would
i'd suck to be in your in
your partners your significant other's body i
think it would be interesting to be
in my in klopp's body and to
experience getting horny for me shot
what have you done though oh look
you'd find out she was lying no
i would understand it suddenly go oh
oh that's what i see and that's
what she sees me yeah but wouldn't
you see yourself the same way as
you do in the mirror and then
you'd be like oh maybe no no
because you've never seen yourself outside of
your body yeah hey maybe you've never
approached yourself in a room i don't
want to
oh yeah i don't need to i'll
tell you that no thanks i'd punch
myself right in the fucking face you
asshole
thanks for nothing by the way i
played softball on the field of dreams
when i went to big slick kansas
city
and that was fun what is big
slick that's the charity thing that ah
paul rudd and and dave koechner and
all the all the st louis yeah
ah go so ass i'll see his
wife slick i forgot why they call
it big slippery that's salt lake city
when i just say st louis s
tio but we got yeah so then
there's nose cancer just kansas
city like kansas city i'm not listen
kansas city kansas or kansas i'm trying
to make centura i didn't make any
sense just now both what i'd throw
if it's all the kansas city's yeah
i thought we were in both the
song we were in both states for
the various things that we did because
there's like a celebrity bowling tournament when
i see a celebrity i'm talking about
people like me that i that i
actually apologize to the
people for because there are people like
paul rudd there and they were like
no we're fans of your show it
was so nice of him but and
they were like i would do that
show ah hold on it's like you
go into a house you take switched
shoes you talk to the camera mister
rogers switched shoes with shoes oh the
prefer
i've got to switch shoes switch
but but i will say so so
ah the our team captain was really
upset during practice he was really upset
but he got me because he went
around to i'm won't say who it
is because the celebrity he went around
to every person who was there and
said like how good are you at
oh no right on a scale of
one eternally fair
on a scale of one to ten
i was thinking as far as celebrities
go you're asking right you're like i'm
a seven yeah so i said seven
i think interesting and he wrote down
seven and so he picked me for
his toys what did you think he
meant for like how good are you
compared like compared to people who obviously
play softball yeah no no no no
no that
what he meant yeah saying like compared
to all these people here but you
know i too are playing football i
have no idea whether they're good no
but but what either way you lied
what i thought yeah it was as
an idiot who's playing softball how good
do you think you would be at
it sure but you still exaggerated your
bills you were like me oh just
what you were saying was oh put
me on
in your tier list
oh i was like i'm not i'm
not like probably like dave koechner who
is going to be a ten
as far as like idiot celebrities playing
softball that's what that's what i thought
so i was like row seven or
whatever so so he picks me and
i guess everyone else was like i'm
a three year of a two or
whatever compared because the original question yeah
so so during practice i'm like whipping
and swinging at the balls and can't
connect i'm like wow fuck
fuck and he comes around to me
and he's like a seven huh
oh and i'm like oh i'm sorry
i thought you meant like you know
as ah but so anyway so but
the greatest thing my first at bat
first pitch right out to the outfield
over the heads of outfielders i come
back around and then i caught like
a big wine drive out into the
outfield everything in the guys like were
you just were
you like playing us during rehearsal or
something it was a girl number yeah
my chances sports one time at rehearsals
and it's all fantasy stuff oh i
love rehearsing
but it was really quite dense it's
the greatest sports experience of mine now
is this gentleman balls how did they
make this awesome desk so they put
extra ball ingredients in here
i wanna know who said that shit
to you i do too and i
wanna know who the other celebrity was
who the other celebrity was that what
way whose name work you're going to
say but i've got no oh okay
yeah oh wait so i thought that
was just a regular thing joe know
that was a celebrity who was like
okay team cap
mike i'm gonna guess who it is
okay yeah yeah i have an idea
yeah oh i bet you do oh
you bet oh i bet you bet
i do
um so those are the two fields
i think that i know i've never
been on any sort of thing like
that as far as i can recall
um but i do think it'd be
really cool i've played soccer with ted
lasso you know i have not show
that i've done yeah you should he's
such a nice so nice he's just
so nice about you oh
niang is good is nice yes so
nice it makes things nice and it's
okay to be nice comedy of being
nice more than nice he's kind yeah
kindness is not a bad thing no
and this is the first i'm hearing
of this i never knew you could
be nice but you can
i know what deadline so what is
so funny as there's like there's first
the embrace of it then there's a
backlash against it then there's a backlash
against the backlash that there's a backlash
against the backlash that every once in
a while there's a person that's like
it's it's fine for you i like
to show it's fine if you don't
like it's like that's like this tiny
deliver of people here's
how i feel about this lately let
people like things but also let people
not like things yeah because anytime like
like as someone comes out and says
like hey ted lasso sucks or whatever
which i don't even agree with by
the way i want to let that
be known i enjoyed head lasso then
people like pile on them yeah online
and go fuck you you're you know
but you know what i
don't even see so many people saying
ted lasso sucks
people saying like i don't care or
whatever and then people getting mad let
people just like whatever they like and
dislike people not care there was one
meredith kessler on twitter said i've never
seen ted lasso but it's fans that's
what it's talking about yeah they give
me big um ah adult it was
childless adults going to disneyland
vi oh i did see yeah like
us last episode yeah i know and
i thought that was funny but the
responses to it were about the show
not about the fans and people were
like you're you're falling you're falling into
i think this was a trap but
it's like your crew are your create
your reinforcing this in a weird way
this by the way hey life's com
music you like to lasso shouldn't you
be nice about someone saying that well
and that's all that's what a lot
of people noted i was like why
you being so mean yeah but the
whole show's about being nice yes i've
only seen a few episodes but it's
fine i enjoyed it yeah what do
you like good for me absolutely it's
a show that is not hurting anyone
know what the hell cares who cares
out just do whatever you why love
is blind eye to allow so anyhow
we talk about time you leave us
alone leave us alone don't listen to
us drive it
was that kissing chris crocker let's get
him back chris crocker screams suddenly oh
lee britain spending fucker son
betty alone oh my god hey great
neighbor and neighbor no thank you um
no thank you let's take a break
oh
we're back we're back and guess what
i don't i have no earthly conception
you don't okay lord you ever guess
no i'm scared okay i'm pleased to
announce to you but ah it is
time for three-tier oh why didn't i
get many ways i didn't know oil
boy
creature a boy saying that's so cute
three oh boy oh boy wow do
a big cute scott
hey oh come on now he's scared
skewed as i get fucking but you're
a tiny little baby i'm from new
york yeah the only time like that
roger rabbit i needed the body baby
and it's annoying he thinks lady what
the hell you didn't figure that lady
yeah yes rabbit know not of course
only roger rabbit thanks jessica
how dare you their marriage is strong
there's like it's like a dirty thing
that's in one frame where he walks
into a whoa yeah oh yeah yeah
it's gross i read every watch that
did they did they cut it out
of i watched it so many times
when it came out in each successive
time i was liked it less and
less like flying
i like for i'd only seen it
as a kid and then i i
forgot the whole entire plot right it
was kind of chinatown but for cartoons
i don't know that movie oh don't
forget it lauren i may turn i
know the quote that we say yeah
but don't forget it to jake's it's
two chinatowns yeah i know that
maybe it would make more sense if
i watch movie
okay yes
to be
oh my god okay ah this is
a game the three-tier excuse me this
is a three-tier called negative twenty questions
submitted by scott dancey and i hope
he is dancing yeah oh yeah he
credits the concept you're all out there
being dancing he credits the concept to
john wheeler
or
a physicist who created the game as
an example of how consciousness may in
some way bring the universe itself into
existence well i shouldn't have gotten high
before we started the oh shit because
now i'm tripping balls whoa man one
person is the guesser the other two
people each independently select their own person
place or thing classic twenty is it
ah
can be a proper name i wonder
yes it can okay because that's the
person yeah yeah please that counts as
a person place also as a proper
name yes you know how to say
bedroom
you could keep going like going to
be fun why does it um okay
let's not interrupt it so much yeah
because i can't follow what one interruption
is too much it kind of is
derailing it because i have no idea
yeah because maybe you're you're the the
answer to your question is followed by
the next thing i'm i'm glad let's
see if it was
it's not the next but it's coming
up okay lag of law one person
is the guest or the other two
people each independently select their own person
place or thing to be guessed they
do not consult with each other or
know the others selection the guests were
then alternates asking their twenty yes or
no questions to each person each time
an answer
or is given the other person must
revise their selection so that the answer
to the question remains true while staying
true to all previous answers as well
here comes the example
player a is the guesser player b
is thinking of a car players player
c is thinking of frank sinatra awesome
player a to player b are you
thinking of a person player b no
player c silently changes their selection to
a non person oh so even if
it's know you you change okay
hey so i've got it got it
got it player a to player c
are you thinking of something edible player
c yes player c silently changes their
selection from a car to something edible
but not understandable car and so or
inedible oh okay so i said i
wish i could eat a ko and
han and maybe high yeah true for
every question that has been asked right
right
so and then the goal is that
we're thinking of the same thing right
after twenty oh okay so oh so
we don't say it out loud a
team wins if the final guess is
correct and all three people wound up
thinking oh fuck i like this like
yeah yeah alright well it's trippy like
yeah okay let me make sure i
understand it because i'm notorious for thinking
i understand yeah and not usually
you i guess twenty questions or do
you this is you only get twenty
or do you can you guess it
but before twenty or up or on
twenty yeah i think if you guess
it before you guess it yeah but
you might have only have twenty but
god i think you should do twenty
because everyone has to be shifting there's
yeah well let's see why but you
get twenty for each person yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah twenty breach oh wow
so forty questions essentially okay but everyone's
thinking at the same time yeah like
we each have like yeah let's do
it and see how long it takes
okay so maybe we've already seen the
twenty forty thanks of a thing yeah
so lauren you and i think of
the thing and paul will guess oh
look alright well that makes it easy
for me wait but but there's not
three people playing yeah but he's going
i guess and we're each thinking of
two separate things okay okay okay okay
okay okay i thought it was that
we each three would have our own
and though he doesn't he doesn't know
he doesn't think of him but at
the end we all say the thing
yeah okay okay so just think of
the thing
is it a and who's this but
this i'm looking at lauren okay
excuse me for trying to help the
listener sorry okay i'm gonna ask my
question yeah what's too is it a
place
certainly yes
okay
is it
arizona
no so you're still on a place
okay and but it's not arizona
that has been established so if what
if i sound of that dumb if
i isn't arizona to you
right because we're trying to get the
same thing so yeah ok alright
is it heaven no i just to
give you a yeah advice i would
get less specific i know i haven't
played twenty questions and let me ask
the questions you do this okay okay
i'm so i i'm using to learn
and then i think of a word
okay yeah got it guys scott is
it a person place or thing
you can't ask this guy's a person
no sorry i fucked right off
some folks thinking yes the associated it's
it's not a person so change your
things so it's not a person okay
it's not is it a thing
no is it a type of shop
but it's not a thing right it's
a place okay
but but you're thinking playfully means like
city i'm thinking like places like southern
right right right now that's fine but
did we say i'm thinking i'm um
i'm on those lines too okay didn't
we say it wasn't a place no
no it is not a thing it's
not a person so it is my
place yeah that's the only thing left
to play oh okay ahead of about
this okay the place okay so yeah
got it i got my god
got it creepy when they were doing
this question fuck you is it a
shop no is it a city no
is it a very helpful by the
way yeah is it a a a
type of learning establishment no
is it a um museum no
is it a
an outdoor place
like a nature no
is it a second
okay is it a place someone's weight
so we can be true for everything
that i've everything right exactly exactly so
i thought something i have to throw
it out
what were the i got to remember
this way though not for me it's
not i mean to me i'm not
a nature place learning established not a
shop row right okay is it a
sporting event place yes is it a
baseball field no
is it a basketball court stadium ah
did you have your thing i didn't
have yeah you gotta give us a
little bit oh right you have it
in your head already i wish i
could think like ten things just have
them in there yeah all times okay
so last one was it's not a
baseball field okay
but it is a sporting events ah
yes um ah and okay yes i
have one okay is it a tennis
location know if miseq
is it a football field yes
is it a stadium in los angeles
no
is it a steam oh oh la
hola freaking out hodor hodor hodor guy
that was fucking
um ok is it a stadium in
ah new york no
your edible yes is it a stadium
in chicago no
is it a stadium in florida no
is it a stadium in north carolina
no but we haven't been keeping a
number tracking the number of questions by
the way yeah yeah that's fine that's
fine let's just yeah going and is
it a stadium in california know is
it a stadium in kansas
i don't know
is the stadium in minnesota no
is it a stadium in wisconsin no
i don't know stadiums what about states
while there's no space i am naming
all the states stadium in new jersey
know to save a half-full
is it a stadium in indiana no
is it a stadium in iowa no
i hope we're thinking of the same
time i wonder if we are is
it a stadium in wyoming no i
don't know about any football teams but
is it a date that's the state
i know but is this your stadium
in texas yes oh
we're not
shit ah
um ok
oh i hope this is i hope
this is it i hope i'm right
well i don't know of a ning
hold on think of cities is it
a stadium in austin no is it
the stadium in houston know is it
a stadium in show okay hold on
hold on
fuck
austin doesn't have a
seattle to hold on he doesn't know
yet he doesn't know yet
think of other cities and i mean
i am trying to think of of
like the names of stadium think of
the love vote
iq of the love boat cheerleaders would
be guests on the guest stars on
the love boat okay is it a
stadium in dallas yes is it the
dallas cowboys stadium yeah i didn't know
if that's the thing is is like
there's so many now they're named after
like corporation
yeah now it's like a salad i
didn't know what it was called but
what were your first two words just
ah yes my mom oh god i
don't even remember it was a person
i think okay oh i remember either
let's do it again um now we
have a sense yeah you amita yeah
you asked the question okay should we
keep track of the questions
yeah oh i'll count or you get
you count on your account on the
factors yeah i think he's okay okay
i'm gonna think of a thing or
person or place um it is got
it i feel like we should count
on our fingers the number the questions
that we're asked easier because we're we're
supposed to be twenty each yes yeah
okay everyone ready no no hold okay
ah okay okay stop thinking about the
example ones
it's hard to think of anything it's
hard to think of anything really hard
game okay i got one okay lauren
is it a person yes
paul is it a male yes
lauren you're ready lauren is it someone
who's alive yes
all your real or not
yes i'm ready paul is it
a famous actor yes
or are you ready
lauren is it a movie star yes
all you're hitting
paul is it someone over fifty yes
lauren you're ready
lauren is it someone who once starred
on e r no
paul
is it
someone who's won an oscar
remember brad pitt won for producing seven
years a slave
seven years how many years twelve that's
too much snow i agree sounded wrong
um yes okay paul or lauren you'd
need to adjust um okay can we
look stuff up but i know i'm
like i'm not one hundred percent but
yeah okay okay lauren yeah i'm not
either by the way okay fine okay
actually could ah lauren
oh is it oh who's won an
oscar see you asked um lauren is
it someone who had a movie out
in the last year
huh no i don't think so no
okay
paul do you need to change i
don't know if my person you don't
think no i'm good okay you're good
okay paul is it someone over sixty
yes old on okay god you have
a mere fifteen questions left for me
oh no fifteen yeah i wonder if
we
okay so over sixty yeah has won
an oscar right
okay ah lauren
did he ever play the joker
no palti needs to change no i
don't from technicals no okay okay um
paul is over seventy
look at that device in your hand
and tell me she's over seventy but
i'm getting i'm getting a good age
range it's fun to have a good
warren beatty is over seventy
yes he's over seventy okay okay lawrence
change okay over seventy one an oscar
lawrence changing
so we should turn her back yes
okay god i'm gonna repeat costume
lauren has he
is he known for drama yes
okay paul
ah did he win for acting
the academy award no oh my god
oh lauren has to change as hard
oh boy
lawrence gotta change it up
not for alcohol and other littles mulu
was girl going up the tree hey
little guy do it i would if
i could hell yeah i would if
i could climb that tree i would
oh every day get up to the
top of that poem look out at
all my neighbors and be like fuck
you yeah look at that asshole so
much fun but this is hard for
lauren because she's got
find an older actor who's won academy
award not for ack he's a dramatic
premier who's won an academy award for
not practising he's over seventy yeah
and i don't even know
i can't even play anymore yeah i
don't know why me i'm like kind
of out i don't know yeah i
don't even know if i could guess
who it is because it's gotta be
i was thinking it was michael douglas
but but i
think i asked a question about michael
douglas earlier right did he get throat
cancer from cunnilingus
i think you asked that right you
wake up every day in texas
ah yes is there anyone new who's
gotten it from going oh my god
i feel like i'm out too i
can't think of who it is paul
just say who it is robert redford
robert redford yeah it was dandy lewis
until he had to be over seventy
and then i switched yeah pretty hopkins
oh but he's one for acting twice
right right so then i couldn't use
one for directing ordinary people
all right okay and and that's it
he has never produced something that wow
no no no he's been nominated but
never once gotten numbed you know what
that this number alarmed the smell is
really shining but we just won't like
it we should ride time yeah where
we are at a time we gotta
go we do have to go we
love you thank you so much for
listening please
be kind to each other like ted
lasso would
zara yeah and if you don't like
good advice i hope you die in
a fucking fire like ted lasso is
like god and the oils these oils
sorry he dies the dies yeah and
then he's a ghost that's very possible
yeah um if you wanna hear please
subscribe to this if you want here
if you wanna hear me versions go
to stitcher premium or cb world dot
com yeah
yeah and we love you send us
three cheers and if and if you're
hearing it ad-free for the first time
do one of those videos like parents
do with their kids when they get
hearing aids yeah
oh my god like when we take
a break and suddenly there's no commercial
you just start crying and start laughing
alright we love you goodbye bye
uh